so you have this
there's six states but it's crucial
there are these arrows between them and
their unique where you know how to go
from one to the other with the different
operations and so that was what you
would call well-defined and then there's
a whole nother theory model there's two
states and it's clear how to go back and
forth between them and there's this
non-trivial statement that the second
theory is a coarse graining of the first
theory that you can derive the second
theory by forgetting details about the
first year exactly and it is finite
number of states example that just goes
through and we're happy and then the
punchline is once you have an infinite
number of states it is in principle
impossible you'll never know you'll
never know there's no sir universal
principle for doing this right universal
principles are doing to what fork so
here so again I'll do the example so
here at first granted about this high
level theory I can tell this is
consistent with this I can tell that you
know all the behaviors this produce I
can get from of course mating with
beginners this produces and so forth now
say I have a model of process that I
believe is more sophisticated than that
that can be represented by a finite
state machine so I have some theory
right and so for example if we believe
people are furnishings are psychology so
have some theory in which I don't
protect don't I can represent this way
many things become true so for example I
might have two degrees that are actually
equivalent that predict the same
behaviors but just by looking at the
structure of the theories I can't tell
but they do that it's undefined it can
totally do what I can't tell if they
okay technically I can't tell they
recognize the same language all right
I'm thoroughly confused you could be
saying one of two things and you're
probably saying neither but these are
the only ones I can think of one is that
there are systems formal systems
physical systems which cannot be the
coarse graining of some other system or
you're saying that there are systems
which to which the renormalization group
cannot be applied so that no other
system can be gotten by coarse graining
them are you saying either of those two
I'm saying exactly but in that in that
saying consolations let me be explicit I
the renormalization for prescription is
not unique
I can I can I can coarse grain the same
system in two different ways to get two
theories that are incompatible and what
I mean by incompatible is one recognizes
one fundamental object the other one
says it's composit and vice versa
they still are constrained by whatever
the data are that's in theory so they
show them so that means there is always
possible okay okay
there was no rational basis for choosing
between you or at any rate he said
things which have suggested that too
many philosophers and historians of
science stuff so yeah I think it would
be so strong but he would say you're
right that some philosophers overreacted
or whatever risk but his point was
logical to this even though the data are
compatible
maybe you compare it with forming one
theory for instance at the moment the
facts alternative theories you can have
new data there would it's closely
related requires thesis and it's
particularly the claim that two total
theories of the world could be mutually
logically incompatible and yet agree
about all empirical observations it's
also important that demand didn't just
make this as an abstract general
philosophical point he made it in the
specific context of work in mechanic's
right so there was actual mechanical
systems he was it was talking about well
though he didn't realize I had
subsequent people don't do haven't said
it about an academy I guess why this is
a much more general version of it seems
to me though you're adding an extra
ingredient I mean the conversation is
which I'm a little confused about so one
is just saying there are theories of the
world and one is saying that the
evidence that's gathered about the world
is consistent with both those theories
that seems to me to be a pretty big
addition are you saying that as well
that it's not just but I can start with
fundamental theory coarse grain and get
to incompatible theories but rather
those two incompatible theories are also
consistent the evidence that's collected
about the world yes now that would also
be the case
you